I came I saw I copied why Dei must
die if you're not a close follower of
American college campus politics you are
likely to be unfamiliar with a woman who
has been making headlines for over a
month in the US and increasingly around
the world the lady in question one
Claudine gay was president of Harvard
one of the most renowned educational
institutions in the world until she
resigned earlier this month of
plagiarism allegations why does or
should anyone care about this well Gay's
decisions to step down is the
culmination of long running efforts to
address the cancer at the heart of
Western societies the idea that the way
to fix injustices of the past is to
commit injustices today following her
resignation Gay's Defenders were quick
to emphasize the racial dimension of the
story Ibraham X kendi for example
tweeted that racist mobs won't stop
until they topple all black people from
positions of power and influence who are
not reinforcing the structure of racism
and while his claims of this being a
racist campaign are absurd it is true
that gay was not targeted solely for
seemingly adopting the personal motto of
I came I saw I copied she became a focus
of major Harvard donor concerns and a
media campaign led by Christopher rufo a
man I would approvingly describe as a
diversity industry's greatest enemy in
the light of her mindboggling testimony
in Congress do calling for the genocide
of Jews violate Harvard's rules of
bullying and harassment yes or no it can
be depending on the context what's the
context targeted as an individual
targeted as at an individual it's
targeted at Jewish students Jewish
individuals again it depends on the
context it does not depend on the
context the answer is yes and this is
why you should resign these are
unacceptable answers across the board
her statements given alongside the
presidents of MIT and upen revealed the
core of the ideology the entire Western
education system is based on in all its
Glory the oppressor versus oppressed
mindset which no matter how
uncomfortable this may make some viewers
is cultural Marxism says simply that
white people and overperforming
minorities like Indians Jews Chinese
Japanese and korean-americans should be
discriminated against and hiring in
student applications in favor of
underprivileged groups as a result
college campuses on which regular
meltdowns have occurred for over a
decade over such hate speech as dressing
in a Mexican costume for Halloween found
themselves with nothing to say about
pramas demonstrations and the harassment
of Jewish students on their campuses in
the wake of the October 7th attacks but
even that is not painting the full
picture yes gay a darling of the
diversity industry was targeted for her
plagiarism following her complete
failure of leadership and re Rec months
but she was also partially targeted
because of the Assumption if not
outright conclusion that the reason she
was appointed in the first place was to
put it mildly not Merit alone after all
Gay's primary achievement is not Stellar
academic work Exemplar managerial skills
or even Charisma and force of
Personality she was appointed president
of Harvard following a distinguished
career in fields like improving
diversity and researching race and
identity to put a bluntly many people
believe that she's a diversity hire and
the reason she pushed the Dei ideology
that eventually led to her appalling
testimony in Congress is that she is
herself a beneficiary of it to be clear
she has not been forced out for being
black she has been forced out for being
placed in a position for which she had
neither the skills nor the experience to
succeed and then failing in it this is
the rotten Legacy of affirmative action
which as Thomas Soul explained decades
ago and in many of his books since hurts
the very people it is attempting to help
now you do you believe that mandatory
proportional representation benefits
minorities No in fact I think one of the
great handicaps that blacks and other
minorities face across the country is
that they are systematically mismatched
with universities in the admissions
process that is if if Harvard feels that
it must have x% of blacks and if the
pool is such that they can't get x% of
blacks at the same level as the rest of
the Harvard students they're going to
take those blacks who would have
succeeded in some State University and
bring them to Harvard where many of them
will fail something like 1/4 of all the
black students going to MIT do not
graduate you're talking about a pool of
people who scored the 90 percentile in
math whom you are artificially turning
into failures by mismatching them with
the school if allowing students to enter
universities in which they're destined
to fail for the sake of diversity harms
them then what might be said about
hiring people for leadership roles in
major institutions in which they they're
destined to fail this harms not only
them but also the people who work and
study at those institutions I have no
evidence that claudian gay was hired
ahead of better and more qualified
candidates but it is not hard to imagine
that a position holding the prestige
reputation a nearly million dollar a
year salary the role of Harvard
president commands could have been
filled by someone with more executive
experience academic achievements and
other relevant expertise this is the
other great curse of the
counterproductive attempts to
artificially increase the presence of so
called underrepresented groups in
employment and education because
everyone knows that some people are
regularly given unfair preferential
treatment it becomes easier and easier
for the rest of us to suspect specific
individuals of being there for reasons
other than Merit so here's the truth we
must return to pursuing the goal of a
colorblind Society immediately there is
no such thing as positive discrimination
all discrimination is wrong and because
it is wrong it will create precisely the
kind of resentment that Claudine gay is
now facing she's seen as the standard
bearer of the Dei industry and is being
treated as such by people who've had
enough all of us must be treated on the
content of our character when we refuse
to follow this principle we hurt
everyone white black Hispanic Asian
Jewish a healthy Society relies on the
equal treatment of all individuals the
fact that we have to say this out loud
in 2024 is a sign of how far we fall
Dei must be dismantled this will take
years perhaps decades but in recent
weeks for the first time in a long time
we have grounds for
optimism before you go let me take a
minute to recommend a longevity
supplement by Verso in our recent
interview with Tim Urban he said we
should be talking about longevity and
Longevity science researchers like the
biologist David Sinclair have recently
made some fascinating discoveries on how
to mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that's why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products that I take
every day is cell beinging cell being
helps combat aging by increasing
something called NAD Plus in your body
now NAD is arguably the most important
molecule in your body high NAD levels
improve your metabolism repair damaged
DNA and and increase energy production
in your brain immune system and muscles
but as you grow old your body's NAD
levels go down and you can't take NAD as
a supplement because it's too big for
your cells to absorb that's why Verso
cell being contains nmn resveratol and
TMG these three molecules work together
to increase NAD plus levels if you want
to read more about this check out the
scientific research Linked In the
description of this video plus Verso
publishes third party testing on every
batch of its product product to
guarantee that you're getting exactly
what you're paying for so if you want to
join me you can get 15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.o and use our code trigger to save 15%
off your
order by the way if you enjoyed this
video then make sure to check out this
one where I explain to Glenn Beck why
diversity is not a
strength